- [Southern accent]
"If you wanna play football
you just gotta go
out there and do it."
- I'm double-jointed.
Look at this stuff.
Boom! Boom!
You can't do that.
- You were Frank the Tank
that night.
- Yeah, I was Frank the Tank.
For sure. [Laughing]
♪♪♪
- Yo, welcome to
"Simms & Lefkoe."
How you doin', pal?
- What's up, man?
Stay over there, OK?
- Dude, do not
Hue Jackson me right now.
- That's what you are,
you're Hue Jackson.
I'm Baker, man.
- Are you Baker Mayfield?
- I don't know.
- I'm Hue Jackson?
- Yes.
- That's really offensive.
Let's just start there actually.
So that was a big social moment
that I don't know
who's right, who's wrong.
Baker was like,
"He went to my rival."
And Hue's like,
"I'm just tryin' to be
your friend, buddy."
Which side are you on it?
Cuz I'm seeing a lotta people
disciplining Baker.
- Well, I don't know
if I would discipline Baker.
I have no problem
with what Baker did as a
I mean, as a player?
OK, he said hello to him,
he shook his hand.
I mean, I didn't know they were
supposed to have
a bromance on the field.
So he's a competitor.
- Yeah, I think Hue wanted, like,
the hug and, like
the whisper in the ear
and all that stuff.
- Well, there was obviously
something that has gone on
that's rubbed Baker
the wrong way.
Whether that's, he's gone
to work for the Bengals
or maybe the fact that Hue
was such a staunch Tyrod Taylor
defender from the start—
- Gotcha.
- To where I think there's
gotta be something more there.
- Yeah, like if Gruden went
to the Panthers midseason
and left the Bucs, you wouldn't
be hugging him and whispering.
- I mean, maybe.
It depends on how
that relationship was prior.
- Gotcha.
Well, your relationship—
- But I could tell you certainly,
I would not be happy
if my head coach left
to go to a division rival that
you have to play twice a year.
- I just listen to all this noise
of people
telling Baker to grow up
and I say, "No, this is exactly
what Cleveland needs."
- Sure.
- I've been waiting for someone
to get in there and say,
"Screw all of you, double birds
we're the Cleveland Browns."
- He's the guy.
- This is the guy.
- He's being the leader.
He's got incredible moxie.
He's got incredible talent.
- Don't, don't love someone
for bein' like Brett Favre
and then when they do
a Brett Favre thing, go
"Oh, that's too much
Brett Favre."
- Well, don't—this
is the conundrum athletes
are in right now, more
than anything, is you know
when they care too much,
"Hey, man
relax, it's a business."
And then when they
don't care, it's
"Oh, I wish they cared more like
the college players. They care."
- Yeah.
- So you can't win sometimes.
Baker cares a lot.
He wants to win.
He didn't wanna give the
lovefest to Hue after the game
- I get it.
- And they gotta play him
again later on this year—
- Yeah.
- So he wants to beat
his butt then, too.
- Well, let's continue
the Cleveland Browns lovefest.
- Oh, let's do.
- We have ourselves
a correspondent
you may say, in Cleveland.
Rookie Denzel Ward having
a great year at cornerback.
- Yep.
- And he went around
to a bunch of the Browns
and tried to find some hidden
talents on the Browns roster.
- I'm Denzel Ward.
We're here at Feed the Need
in Cleveland, Ohio.
Let's see what talents
these guys got.
I heard you got a hidden talent.
What would that be?
- I think of myself
as a pretty good chef, you know?
I throw down in the kitchen
a little bit.
- OK.
What's your favorite dish?
- Um, I'm kind of
a meat-and-potatoes guy
so I do a pretty good steak.
I do, like, a reverse sear
on it, on my smoker.
I like it, my wife likes it,
so we're good.
- Make sure y'all get this, man.
- One, two, three, four,
I declare a thumb war.
- Oh, got him!
- OK.
- Got him!
- I got my quarterback
Baker Mayfield.
I heard you got
an impression, Baker.
- So, Freddie Kitchens,
our offensive coordinator.
- What you see is what
you get with Baker.
- He's, uh, born and raised
in Alabama, so—
[Southern accent]
He talks like this.
"Hey, man.
If you wanna play football,
you just gotta go out there
and do it.
I mean, if you love the game,
you gotta do it."
- Yeah, he thinks he's a lot
more funny than he really is.
- We'll be doing this all day.
Hey, I'm slippery.
- Oh, he got, he got
that baby oil on.
- My impression for you guys
today would be
coach Bob Wylie, man.
One of my favorite guys.
He's my coach, my O-line coach.
- Set. Hut!
Set. Hut!
- "Set. Hut!
Set. Hut!"
Set. Hut!
[Laughing]
- Three, two, one...
Aw, I think that's a draw.
- It's a draw.
It's a draw.
- Wow.
That was great, Denzel.
- I've seen better.
Good thing you guys
are playin' good football.
- Seriously.
- Because your talent off
the field is questionable.
- Do you have any hidden talents?
- Yeah, I'm double-jointed.
Look at this stuff.
Boom! Boom!
You can't do that.
I can moonwalk, too.
And I was born on the same day
as Michael Jackson
but there is no effing way
I'm moondancing—
moonwalking on this show.
- "Moondancing."
- Yes.
- You can moonwalk
for real, though?
- I can, yeah.
- For real for real?
- Right. For real for real.
- I can do the alphabet
backwards, and I know a lot
of Heisman Trophy winners.
- Oh, wow.
- But my talents aren't hidden.
- Oh, they're right here
in front of you.
- Right in your face.
We have a guy
that's very talented
on and off the field,
Reggie Bush.
It's time for an untold story.
And this is great.
It's the first time in his life
that he got drunk
and it's because of a lady,
and not just any woman.
- Ooh, not just anyone.
Everyone thinks you're, like,
Johnny Superstar over here.
- Yeah.
- Like, you must've been
sex, drugs and rock 'n' roll
in college.
- Right?
- Right, yeah.
- But, like, we know that
you're this—
When was the first time
you had a drink?
- 22 years old was the first time
I had a drink.
- Damn.
- But you did have a drink at 22?
- Yeah, I did.
- Why all of a sudden?
- Well...
it was, uh, to impress a chick.
- Ohh.
- We were in Vegas.
We went to Tao.
And this was back when Tao was
like, you know,
it was at its highest.
- Big time.
- It was at its peak.
- Huge Buddha—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, huge Buddha.
Right.
- Champagne bottles, you know
coming nonstop,
and the first drink
I decide is gonna be
my first drink ever is Patron.
- Ooh.
- Straight from the bottle.
No chasers.
Just straight tequila.
- What I can't get over is,
you're Reggie Bush
and you're the man,
and you needed
the liquid courage?
- For whatever reason,
I needed the liquid courage
to get me there.
- You did.
- To get me to that point.
And I blacked out.
- Right.
- I wake up the next morning.
There's—my throat is burning.
I don't know why my
throat's burning.
Then I look on the side
of the bed.
There's throw-up all
on the side of the bed.
- Ohh.
- And I'm like, "Damn."
Like, "What happened?"
- [Laughing]
- I got the hangover from hell.
- The hangover.
- The hangover from hell.
So I'm, like, drinking water
and all kinds of stuff.
The next day,
all my boys was like
"Man, you were
on fire last night."
I was like, "Really?
What'd I do?"
One of my other boys was like
"You turned into
the Incredible Hulk.
Like, you just get really strong
for no reason."
They were like,
"You were pickin' people up
you were movin' people
out the way."
- Oh my God. I've seen
those guys before.
You were Frank the Tank
that night.
- Yeah, I was Frank the Tank.
- So big star, Heisman Trophy,
rich Reggie Bush—
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did it work at least?
- It did.
- OK.
- Um, it worked.
Um, but...yeah, it was just
one of those—
- There was a big price to pay.
- It was a big price to pay.
- Hopefully Reggie is not
on the hot seat
with his lady at home after.
- Yeah, thanks for putting
his life on blast.
- He told the story.
- He knew what he
was signing up for.
- Comfortable setting.
It is that time of the year
though, where people are talking
about coaches on the hot seat.
All right, so here's
what I want you to do.
I'm gonna give a coach's name.
You give me the amount
of fire emojis—
- Gotcha.
- In which their seat
is represented in hotness.
- Right, right.
- First one's Mike McCarthy
and the Packers.
- Whoo!
- Hot seat?
- Ooh.
It's like—
I mean, on the emoji scale?
I'm gonna give it about
a six right now, OK?
- Six of 10?
- Six of 10, yes.
I mean, hey, Mike McCarthy
I think that we all know some
of the struggles they've had
lack of imagination
with their offense.
They have Aaron Rodgers,
who is certainly one
of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time.
I don't think anybody
would argue that.
- No.
- And it's not been good lately.
They have not
supported him well.
It's been a lot of Rodgers
making it happen on its own.
- Right.
- And I think people
are finally realizing that.
- It's the first year
where I'm seeing people
actively blame him for this.
- Yes. Right. Exactly.
- So it's interesting.
- Right.
- Let's go with another tenured guy.
- Yeah.
- Second-longest-tenured coach
in the NFL.
Marvin Lewis.
- Ooh.
Man, that's—
- The seat's, I thought
it's been hot for years,
but it's never happened.
- Well, it's hot, certainly.
I mean, my cheeks are warm.
- How many?
- I'm giving it seven
emojis there.
- So more than McCarthy.
- More than McCarthy, yeah.
I just think that the way
the Bengals have played lately
the defense basically
falling apart, I mean—
- And it's supposed to be his defense.
- Has a chance to set
the record for most yards
allowed in that full season.
You know, lack of playoff wins.
He's had a good run.
I just think, hey,
everything's gotta
come to an end at some point,
and the organization seems like
it's kind of plateaued
the last few years.
- All right, what about
Dirk Koetter
and the Tampa Bay Bucs?
- Yeah, that's hot.
I mean, that's burnin' hot.
So hot—
- Want to tou—
- I think he's going to get fired.
- OK.
- I wanted to keep it PG.
- You did a good job, yeah.
- Thank you very much.
I mean, I think that's like,
a nine emoji.
Nine fire emoji.
- Wow.
- Yes.
- So you're pretty sure
it's over?
- I think so.
I mean, they've really made
no progress the last few years.
There's been
the quarterback issues.
You had to fire Mike Smith.
You know, they finally got
some offensive talent
down there last year
with DeSean Jackson—
- Yep.
- And people—and nothing's
really happened.
They're not winning
football games.
- They don't have
an identity still.
- So, exactly right.
I think he's done.
- Let's stay local.
- Yeah.
- New York Jets. Todd Bowles.
- Whoo!
Hot.
Ten emojis.
Hundred emojis.
My—yeah, it's over.
- Oh, that one's like the chair's
already in flames.
- I mean, put the whole screen
in emojis, OK?
It's done, yes.
I mean, from what Todd Bowles—
You know, again, you made
the playoffs the first year
but ever since then,
it's been underwhelming, OK?
Then this year, you draft
a rookie quarterback
you get off to a decent start,
and then the team falls apart.
Losses like to the Buffalo Bills
at home where you get blown out?
That's not gonna save your job.
They just haven't made
a lotta progress
and I do, I think you're
gonna see a regime change.
- He got the dreaded,
"We'll examine this
after the season."
- Yes. Right
- When you hear that,
impending doom.
- Yes.
- But we don't want any of
these guys to get fired.
- No, we like them.
It's just part
of the business and—
- But if you wanna hire me
as head coach
#Lefcoach is a pretty darn
good hashtag.
- Whoa. Yeah. That—
well, that'd be good.
- I'm Brian Westbrook,
and you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
- So for Thanksgiving,
we had to bring
Allie the Oracle back.
Gave him three games
and I'm just gonna tell you,
the dude nailed it.
Let's go back to
Allie's news stand.
- Not one, not two,
but three games on Thanksgiving.
You did the damn thing.
I'm watchin' and I'm goin',
"He's gonna hit all."
You're now 5-1,
but more importantly
on Thanksgiving,
you made $346.32.
This is turning into
a nice little side gig, Allie.
- Adam, I'm not even
gonna lie to you.
I didn't know we were betting.
- What do you mean?
- I—we didn't talk money.
I thought you guys
was just coming back
cuz we were friends.
- I only talk money.
Straight cash, homie.
- I love it.
- Are you serious?
You really didn't know
that was happening?
- Absolutely not.
- Good.
- We didn't talk no cash.
We were friends talkin'
about football, that's it.
- This game I think could be
the game of the week.
Dallas is hosting the Saints
and the Saints are 7.5-point
favorites in Dallas.
You just won on the Saints
last Thursday.
What are you thinking
for this Thursday?
- I won on Dallas, too, though.
- That's true.
They both hooked you up.
- But, 7.5 in Dallas, you gotta go
with Drew Brees. Gotta go with the Saints.
- You're feeling it right now?
- Yes. Drew Brees is clicking.
I don't think that Dallas'
defense is gonna get to him
enough to shake him up.
- That is the key.
- Yep.
And make sure you tell
your buddy Chris—
- Yeah.
- That went against me
with every game last week—
- Chris went 0-3
on "Simms & Lefkoe," yeah.
- I'm the Oracle.
[Laughing]
- So, my big, beautiful best
friend, other than you
Allie is back.
3-0 last week.
He's goin' Saints.
Minus-7.5.
- Big time. Yeah, how dare
he takes a shot at me.
- He took a big shot at you.
- I mean—
- Stared down the camera.
- Geez.
I know where your stand is.
I will come find you, and—
- He might like that though.
- Didn't he already lose?
Why is he on this show still?
He's 5-1 on the season.
You went 0-3 last week.
- I mean, we're recycling guests
already, but OK.
- Who are you goin',
Saints or Cowboys?
- I'm goin' with him
this week, yeah.
I like the Saints
in this matchup.
I don't think it's a good
matchup for the Dallas Cowboys.
- OK.
- Dallas Cowboys
that great run offense?
Well, it's the No. 1
run defense in football.
If there's a weakness to the
Saints, it is their secondary.
I don't know if Dallas'
pass game's good enough
to take advantage of it.
And as awesome
as Dallas' defense is
and their defensive front,
I think you and I both agree
the best offensive line
in football
is the New Orleans Saints.
- And Drew Brees gets the ball
out in, like, two seconds.
- Exactly right.
With Sean Payton game-planning
all of that together,
I just like their matchup.
- I'm hoping Zeke really finds
some lanes and pounds them—
- Right.
- And we see how the Saints
handle that kind of a game.
- That kinda game, ugly.
- The only other thing
I'm gonna say is
no team in the NFL had
a better week last week
than the New England Patriots.
Chiefs lost to the Rams.
- Right.
- Melvin Gordon's hurt, and
they play the Chargers next week.
- Yep.
- Pittsburgh loses a game to Denver.
And don't look now, New England
is firmly in the 2 seed
one game behind the Chiefs.
- Yeah.
- And we might be lookin'
at the Patriots
gettin' home-field advantage
outta nowhere. It's crazy.
- Well, I mean, this is why
I told you to get the tattoos.
I said this was what it was.
I mean, what you,
you doubted me?
You doubted me. That's—
- Well, I'm just gonna listen to
Allie from now on.
- What?!
I picked those winners.
I just didn't pick the spread.
Screw betting.
I'm goin' to find Allie.
I'm gonna kick his butt.
- For Simms.
- Peace out, Allie and homies.
- I'm the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man. Sorry.
- Yes!
We will holla, holla, holla
atcha later.
- Damn, I'm flustered.
- Enjoy the games.
Allie's in his head!
- Ohh baby.
- Fellas.
- Lookin' good.
- What's goin' on, man?
- Damn.
- How y'all doin'?
- Could you get a tighter shirt?
- This is actually—
- I do like that he's got
the top button buttoned.
- This is actually a
lot—yes, I see it.
That's swag right there.
- I think you're getting
more muscular
as you get ready for fall.
I mean—
- You would fumble more now.
- Right.
Arm's too big, right?